Diablo 3 ultimate evil edition is out
today yes on ps4 ps3 xbox 360 and Xbox
one yep oh wait is it it's just a bit
nevermind yeah yes yes and you've got it
here and you're dressed in like a real
stylish purple getup
yes Saints Row 4 let me see it nice here
dude oh you want to see my dear yeah one
now come on give me the glamour yeah so
creepy I mean I guess we'll get it out
of the way like one of the one of the
cool things new things that you can do
is you can kind of play dress-up it's
like one of the things they kind of I
don't know if you want to say borrow or
not from the stole of Warcraft said it
all right fine stole whatever so let's
say for example you have your helmet
right sure you're how my commanders
siphoned yeah my commander safe you can
go in and depending on this is some of
the stuff you get as you train up so
tiny but uh you get define or like what
you want your commander siphon dome to
look like yeah so as you find like
legendaries and new items and whatnot
it'll add to your portfolio of things
that you can change your outfit to so
look I'm gonna make my guy look like
shredder now yes
so like yes he shredded wheat yeah so we
go shred some things all right I'm gonna
go shred something didn't they get
around that in the web thing because
people who had like the best epic year
some of it just looked like absolute ass
together so they just let you kind of
yeah I mean one of the cool things about
that though was there were certain items
you could you couldn't like just use it
on anything else to make it more special
but anyways this is uh this is one of
the new elements in this version of the
Diablo game all diggity evil edition
it's a bounty which is like a little
mini quest within the world you have an
objective that you have to fill or
complete I have to kill blood in the
skull and kill 100 monsters I hate that
guy but it's cool yeah notice I have a
little fuse thing in the middle of the
screen
33 kills 34 kills 41 kills 42 kills yeah
so that's going to keep going it's like
one of them you kind of I I don't want
to call it a carrot on a stick but it's
kind of fun and it makes you try to keep
killing things
is there a score multiplier yeah gives
you more XP yeah you just got 2.5 times
the
experience does that do you find now
you've leveled in Diablo the many times
over on the PC version especially do you
find that that massacre mechanic is
helped you level a little faster I
definitely did in certain cases because
as you can see that the exp multiplier
is pretty high on certain things that
like a curse chest event or something
like that where I've gotten like 200
kills before and that you know obviously
will help you level up faster I am
trapped now but yeah I think it's also
it's like a little fun mechanic that is
very constantly um you know just keep
going do you always keep this many
people in these bounty missions like I
usually like just because this is not
regular Diablo I feel like you're not
you feel against not many low-level
characters right oh I mean the density
has increased quite a bit since this in
this iteration
yeah but bounties generally have pretty
good monster density in terms of like
how many monsters are fighting I think
though sometimes I feel like the harder
the difficulty you set it on the more
monsters are I don't think that's always
the case I think it's actually more area
based but uh there's always a lot of you
know grunt kind of monsters that you can
kill to kind of extend your multiplier
there's also another thing so like
there's these traps now if there was
stuff there which sadly there wasn't
there's an old Oh that guy's fine no it
had to be this trap that's all that but
yeah if there was monsters there you
would get a trap bonus which you don't
actually get in PC okay another thing so
there's all these different little
multipliers that you get on this console
version who's your boy den PC that is
the Templar that's a one of the
followers that you get okay
is that Shay Patrick Cormac sure okay
little Assassin's Creed unity Reverend
thank you yeah I got your daddy that's
what that's my god first of your
references I've got today the rest of it
has just been like you better hope miss
dynamite doesn't turn up in this video
game folks just a quick reminder right
now if you have any questions for Eric
about the ultimate evil edition of
Diablo 3 go ahead and tell to us in the
chat at twitch.tv slash GameSpot or in
the comments at GameSpot calm and I'll
take a look at him and send him his way
I've already got a few lined up that I'm
gonna ask you in just
sexer i also want to remind you folks
that we are giving away codes for
counter spy a game you're gonna see
demoed later in the show all you need to
do to be entered to win is follow
GameSpot on Twitter and retweet the
giveaway tweet that GameSpot just
tweeted except eat wheat subs or tweet a
bunch there yeah it's the key to all the
functioning of this new society we live
in yeah
Eric eggs wants to know why you're not
playing a monk
yes switch it up every now and then also
the last time I was here on the lobby
for the PC version I played monk so you
know give the people or something fresh
to see you want to show people that you
have range yeah yeah you can diversify
exactly speaking of which what's the
like playing on the controller as
opposed to messing keyboard does Danny
echoing Red Hat Drew's question as well
at hyper floods question oh that guy
likes Linux I will say I was very
skeptical the first time I played on
console even when a Diablo 3 came out on
console but I have to say it's actually
quite fun it works out better than you
think it would it's hard for me to
explain that because it's like you have
to try it yourself but he's actually
very fluid it plays very well I was
telling Chris before we started because
he was like hey do you think you would
play this over PC and I was like well I
probably wouldn't play it over PC but if
I didn't play PC and I had a lot of
friends that were playing on console
yeah just because they want to play on
console this is a great game do you play
differently at all like do you approach
it differently like um was there
anything that you thought would be more
challenging on a controller that's
that's not hmm not really so there's
this other mechanic too that's in the
game there's this like little roll here
yeah this is not on PC right it's
supposed to help you maneuver certain
things because you know mouse it's
obviously more precise you can click
where you want yeah this kind of just
you know you can roll the way you want
to the thing is for me like playing a
demon hunter like he has a skill that
can kind of eBay door right so since
that's better I'm not using the roll but
I could see melee classes using the role
of huh more often because it's like oh
there's you know freezing poles on the
ground or something you want to get away
from it that's a fast way instead of
just kind of like panic running a little
bit like ranged like you're trying to
catch up with dudes when you're trying
to keep that multiplier up right yeah
exactly
sorry what about like ranged AoE stuff
like trying to like do somebody in the
back in the distance you can do that I
think that the screen is a little bit
more like limited than PC like I think
if I was doing that on PC because it's
zoomed out more I'm ready okay it might
actually hit stuff further away so on
this it's gotta at least be on the edge
of the screen I feel like for it to
actually hit like within that corner of
the screen well yeah so let me I'm not
really following to find the butcher
since I'm talking that's alright but I'm
gonna show you what you would get if you
finish the bounties oops
you get some one of these currencies for
the like Nephilim rift yeah so you get
rift key stones as you finish each
bounty and then if you finish a whole
axe bounty you get a reward which is
whoops
still terrible with these controls
what's the menu like I would say it's
it's a little weird for me at first
because coming from PC it's like okay I
is inventory or Lucy is my character
whereas like this is like pressing the
touchpad and then like but the start
button is also for other things so it's
just kind of getting my head wrapped up
getting through all this is alright yeah
this is alright I mean like this is the
only thing like if you're playing
locally that would kind of slow you down
is like if I wanted to change an item or
a skill or something like that which
happens from time to time I would have
to pause you'd have to wait I don't
think it's like that when you're playing
online but they do have like a quick
inventory kind of like like okay
shortcut way the only thing is you can't
tell her you can see that like cycling
just above on the right on the left side
of the screen just above all the his
like health skills yeah so I think these
are just the items that I have in my
inventory that I could switch to right
it's harder to tell like to to shields
means like you're getting more life or
resistance you don't actually get to see
what it is you're going into your
inventory but yeah so anyways this is
what you would get from if you finish it
oh that I'll tell you about that gift
thing too so you get a hoorah Juke crap
cache sorry
oh man and it drops a bunch of things
there Templar stealing all your stuff no
that's me
but those bounty bags and have Act
specifically Legendary's that you can
actually get which are really good
certain acts have like really good ones
like act one has a ring
that's yeah pretty much changing man how
does it change the game to like a
sampling on what it is is that that ring
helps you get your set bonus is easier
it takes away like the requirement of
like one extra thing so like if to get
like if you could have a four out of
five yeah to get that bonus you can
still have the four out of five and you
get that right so then you get the rifts
Keystone currencies which then you put
into this obelisk Nephilim obelisk
sorry and it lets you go into a Nephilim
rift which is another kind of new thing
if this is what they add like a PC one
yeah a couple months Garrett go deep
into the lore what is a Nephilim
it's a so like an oculus rift but it's
like a different company they're doing a
kind of a cheap version of it yeah but
in this game it's if I remember the
story right it's like enough along Jesus
it's not stitches no it's looks like
sketches on what's the who stitches
stitches is the [ __ ] dude from
discord in World of Warcraft you just
yeah wrongdoer he was in the lease that
you did not mess with on the path
stitches is in heroes of the storm go as
a mo yeah well he's from Warcraft right
yeah yeah or his people his type are far
more one of the cold again a bombs
they're abomination abominations yeah
yeah hey bombs I think the the lore
behind the Nephilim or the like which is
who you are is like you're powerful
being I believe that is like descended
upon like descended from like the angels
and whatnot look yeah definitely so
you're supposed to have you know be more
powerful than a human but you
specifically and so you're able to go
into the Nephilim Rift and get it's
basically the pay it's just they're more
challenging that's the idea the Nephilim
risk what they're supposed to be are
kind of like a random randomized dungeon
that has you know like different areas
with different monsters which is
something that's not it's like that
wasn't part of the game is it's all
story
it's like monsters that wouldn't have
necessarily been in one area it's like
totally randomized right yep yeah so
this just gives people a way to match
the Horde abomination oh go go to
different levels oh my god legendary
sweet oh no it's a recipe that sucks
that's literally you went from one end
of the spectrum to the other yeah I mean
like it's good for later such this
emotional experience Diablo 3 is it evil
is there anything like you're playing
this you know because your must have fun
is there anything in this that if there
are folks at home were playing this on
PC that they should feel compelled to
get in on this um it's hard to say like
I said if you're hardcore into PC you're
probably not playing this and I think
Blizzard knows that because they've
they've come out and said plenty of
times that they feel like this market
like the console market is for you no
different than their PC market yeah like
I said a blow game was on consoles
before yeah you're right she was on
PlayStation 2 right uh I think Diablo 1
was on PlayStation 1 and then like they
didn't do it for Diablo - oh really but
what about that couch co-op couch co-op
is fun I mean I remember when we when
deep when we first got Diablo 3 under in
the office uh when Carolyn was playing
and and the rest of them they were
having more fun than they thought they
would yeah and I think couch co-op is a
like you said it's like a it's a very
fun kind of thing and hyper flood wants
to know does it like is there slow down
or does it still run very smoothly when
you've got more players on screen it's
fine I think they they've tuned the game
to you know respond properly for you
know for people even if you have a bunch
of skills going on at the same time I
think that's another reason why they
actually only limited it to four people
it used to be eight and Diablo 2 but
well I think there's so much stuff on
this seems excessive yeah well it was
also complaints by people that there
wasn't a but there's so much stuff
happening on the screen that I could see
why they can have eight people yeah so
it's four couch go off you can play
online co-op you can do all sorts of
character transfer stuff if you folks
want to know more about Diablo 3
ultimate evil edition we did an hour
livestream with to Diablo developers on
the game and they've delved into like
all sorts of stuff to do with the
transfer of the game from PC to consoles
what kind of content you're getting in
and what kind of obstacles I had
overcome to put it on console what kind
of adjustments they've made and how
co-op works and online connectivity and
importing your character the whole
shebang
but Erte Diablo 3 ultimate evil edition
thanks for coming on showing us thank
you for having these right as well it
didn't come out and PlayStation 2 hey
man he knows it all I got it I got on
the down
fact-finding thanks Annie we don't up to
it thank you